I just had the most frightening walk
from the train station I walk to the
train station in the morning and I
commented to Grace how nice it was so
it's day 13 951 p.m. nice of a walk in
the morning it's very pleasant and the
people I mean people taking their kids
to school people walking the dog and
it's like you and there's leaves but
grace said to me that at night when you
walk it really sucks she's usually right
about everything so as I was walking
today I had my hair in pigtails I very
quickly made this decision to take out
both my pigtails I figured I would less
like a subject of pray to men yeah
and women anyone who might want to pray
upon me so I made a left onto a side
road it was a dead end so I was like
crap what am I gonna do I can't cut
through these houses if you if I was
with someone I would have had the
gumption but I was too chicken so I
turned around and I look on the ground
and there's a sign that says dead end
there's someone knocking over all of the
important street signs I I was literally
holding mace never used it yet
pepper spray whatever they're different
even though if anyone actually
approached me I probably like or they
probably stab me or shoot me or rape me
before I could even figure out how to
use it then I realized they're not
completely positive what the exterior of
the house looks like
I saw Grace's big car in the driveway
and that was my giveaway I'm supposed to
take the dog for a walk after just
narrowly escaping death it was a
harrowing experience I mean it was only
like 9:30 and sometimes I get back much
later [ __ ] scaring me cliff hi you
smell bad he's rubbing his ass on the
carpet again now he's rubbing his eyes
on the chair and now he's licking his
dick awesome